mais que s'est il passé à l'intérieur du
restaurant christine ne le saura pas
lorsqu'elle revient enfin à la pizzeria
vers 20 heures charlie son mari
l'empêchera d'ailleurs d'être trop
curieuse
charleville ans ferme il enferme dans
l'appartement
non
le havre en normandie 2 avril 1996
il est 4 heures du matin il fait encore
nuit angela et alain est 46 et 48 ans
quittent leur domicile à bord de leur
mercedes
une longue route les attend car le
couple se rend à 800 km de là à mulhouse
ils ont rendez vous avec un certain
charles traiter l'eau à qui ils veulent
proposer de s'associer pour racheter un
restaurant ils l'ont rencontrée par
hasard et ils ont sympathisé
à l'arrêt veut parler à charlie traiter
l'eau d'un restaurant
intéressant s'appelle heureux de
l'afrique qui serait sur le raf qui sera
en vente et que ce serait une affaire à
faire si charlie traiter l'eau était
d'accord pour investir
après cinq heures de route alain est et
son épouse arrivent à mulhouse ils
déposent leurs valises dans un
appartement de cette résidence un petit
pied-à-terre qu'il partage avec un
couple d'amis
une heure plus tard ils reprennent la
route car leur rendez vous doit avoir
lieu à 20 km de là dans le village de
rosenau ou leurs futurs associés possède
une pizzeria avant de partir ils ont
annoncé à leur ami qu'ils n'en auront
que pour quelques heures et qu'ils
rentreront pour le dîner
mais les heures passent la nuit tombe et
le couple ne rentre pas
[Musique]
le lendemain
alain et angela n ont toujours pas
réapparu
l'un de leurs amis marcel ancien un
garagiste se montre un peu inquiet
alain avait l'habitude de me téléphoner
on est dix fois par jour et depuis le
joli je n'ai plus aucune nouvelle
donc ça m'a intrigué plus inquiétant
encore angela et alain n'ont pas non
plus téléphoner à leurs enfants et cela
ne leur ressemble pas
mal les enfants étaient angoissés parce
que le père leur téléphoner
régulièrement leur téléphoné plusieurs
fois par jour c'est pareil c'était un
adepte du téléphone et téléphoner tout
le temps et du jour au lendemain a plus
aucune nouvelle ça c'est anormal ce
n'est pas possible la plus inquiète
c'est la fille d'alain est céline comme
elle n'a aucun moyen de joindre son père
elle a l'idée de consulter son compte
bancaire pour vérifier ces dernières
transactions est ce qu'elle va trouver
ne va pas les rassurer ce qui inquiète
c'est lenner rapidement c'est que outre
l'absence de nouvelles va effectivement
découvrir que ses parents ont fait
retraits d'argent liquide de important
puisque
il ya eu un retrait de 500 m
[Musique]
c'est pas dans les habitudes sortir une
telle somme sauf pour faire une
opération
particulière il affaires commerciales et
mais si ç'avait été le cas évidemment
tout le monde aurait été prévenu est en
forme et ça ce qui n'a pas été le cas
cette fois là cinq cent mille francs en
liquide l'équivalent de 75 mille euros
pourquoi alain et angela ont-ils retiré
une somme aussi importante
autre élément inquiétant les amis du
couple ont retrouvé dans les affaires
d'angela des médicaments dont elle ne se
séparait jamais
ng là elle avait des douleurs de la
colonne vertébrale je crois elle avait
des anti-inflammatoires tout ça elle
était partie sans ses médicaments et ça
c'était anormal parce qu'elle était
toujours où qu'elle aille elle avait ses
médicaments sa cause de médicaments
jouets les salles n'avait pas sur elle
alors trois jours après la disparition
d'alain et angela est leur ami marcel va
refaire le trajet de mulhouse à rosenau
il sait que cette route longe le grand
canal d'alsace ils pensent que le couple
a peut-être eu un accident et que leur
véhicule a pu sombrer dans l'eau sans
que personne ne s'en soit aperçu
nous avons longé le rat pendant des
heures et des heures en cherchons s'il
n'y avait pas de traces de chute de
véhicules parce que c'est un véhicule de
choix dans le canal on arrive à avoir
des traces dans l'herbe ou des trucs
comme ça donc il n'y avait pas et à
partir de ce moment là c'est devenu plus
inquiétant marcel on vient et un autre
ami du couple décide alors de demander
conseil à un journaliste du quotidien
l'alsace un spécialiste des faits divers
jean-marie stoerkel
et voici ce qu'ils lui disent
on a des amis qui s'appellait qui ont
disparu depuis vendredi en 5e parce que
le matin ils ont récupéré dans une
banque à mulhouse cinq cent mille francs
en billets de 500 francs ils sont partis
à rosenau cheese à un ami restaurateur
puis deux puis on est à plus haut jamais
revu
mais l'élément qui va interpeller
jean-marie stoerkel c'est le nom du
restaurateur de rosenau
charlie traiter l'eau
des années je connais et si ce
spécialiste des faits divers connaît
bien charles traiter l'eau ce n'est pas
un hasard
l'homme est un repris de justice il a
été condamné pour complicité
d'assassinât seize années plus tôt la
victime était un garçon de café de la
région et le meurtre avait eu lieu dans
la forêt de niffer non loin du grand
canal d'alsace à l'époque charlie crette
l'eau avait fait dix ans de prison face
à cette révélation les amis du couple
disparu décide aussitôt d'alerter la
police
7 avril 1996 au srpj de mulhouse c'est
le commissaire christian aghroum et son
équipe qui sont chargés du dossier ils
prennent immédiatement l' affaire très
au sérieux le fait que deux personnes
qui ont l'habitude de téléphoner tous
les jours à leur famille qu'ils ont
l'habitude de ne pas retirer d'aussi
grosses sommes d'argent et qui retire le
matin même 500 mille francs en liquide
le fait que une fois les leaders
domicile fait on se rend compte les
médicaments que prend angela est tous
les jours sont demeurés au domicile sont
autant d'éléments qui nous amène à
penser que la disparition est
certainement beaucoup plus inquiétante
que dans un cas ordinaires aux yeux des
policiers la première chose à faire est
d'interroger charles traiter l'eau le
restaurateur de rosenau il est le
dernier à avoir vu le couple est et il a
déjà été mêlé à un assassinat il fait
donc un suspect est parfait presque trop
parfait
à la limite ça paraît même trop gros
parce que quelqu'un comme lui qui a fait
des prisons devrait être suffisamment
malins pour éviter de tomber dans ce
panneau d'être le dernier à avoir vu
vivant des gens qui l'auraient tué
les policiers se rendent à la pizzeria
pour interroger le restaurateur
ils sont accueillis par un homme
charmant et détendue
aux tombes au niveau de ce restaurateur
sur une personne très décontracté qu'une
qui nous narre sa version de la journée
de manière tout à fait naturelle charles
nous reçoit dans nous expliquant cela
bien reçu angela et que c'était le jour
de congé d'eux
de la pizzeria qui les a accueillis
qu'ils ont passé des génies ensemble que
les a reçus à déjeuner avec son fils
christophe et qu'ils ont déjeuné tous
les quatre
christophe confirmera les pousses de
charles confirme également que le couple
est venu ils ont déjeuné sur place le
récit de charles traiter l'eau est
parfaitement crédible et aux yeux des
policiers l'ancien criminel paraît très
convaincant les policiers ont dans
l'ensemble ils sont ils sont embêtés
parce que d'un côté un couple qui a
disparu le dernier qui a vu ce couple
vivant sécréter look restelo il a beau
avoir un passé il a payé sa peine il a
payé sa dette et puis il a l'air
parfaitement réinsérer il est avec femme
enfants
il exploite une affaire qui tourne bien
priori il est vrai que depuis sa
libération créé tello n'a plus aucun
problème avec la justice d'ailleurs dans
la région le patron de la pizzeria est
plutôt apprécié un homme très avenante
souriante bon bien sûr c'est un
méridional avec tout ce que ça comporte
le verbe est haut et fort le macho dans
toute sa splendeur
voilà
mais mais mais très charmant charles
traiter l'eau semble donc hors de
soupçons en revanche son d'audition va
fournir aux policiers une nouvelle piste
en poursuivant son récit le restaurateur
explique que le 2 avril alain et angela
et ont quitté sa pizzeria vers 14h30 et
il sait quel était leur prochaine
destination
le couple et était reparti en début
d'après midi pour aller acheter un
véhicule faire une affaire en allemagne
il était sur une sur un coup pour
acheter une ferrari un modèle f50 je
crois
qu'ils devaient acheter 500 mille francs
en espèces et revendre il avait déjà
trouvé le vendeur à l'acquéreur à 700000
donc ils avaient une plus value de 200
mille francs à réaliser comme ça sur une
sorte d' aller retour c'est donc pour
réaliser cette opération câlins et a
retiré cinq cent mille francs en liquide
le matin même mais cette transaction est
elle sur alain on avait parlé à son ami
garagiste marcel et celui ci ne voyait
pas la faire d'un très bon oeil car la
transaction devait avoir lieu de la main
à la main sur un parking
je ne voulais pas qu'ils se rendre à des
rendez-vous comme ça sur un parking on
n'achète pas une ferrari sur un parking
voilà moi j'avais peur qu'ils se fassent
arnaquer dans cette histoire je vais
demander un peu plus de précisions sur
la transaction avait expliqué que ses
adversaires en espèces donc j'ai tout de
suite je vais tout de suite mis en garde
sur le risque de ce genre de choses et
puis sur le fait que c'est strictement
interdit d'ailleurs on avait beau lui
dire fait pas qu'y faisait quand même
s'il avait décidé de faire et faisait
donc je me suis dit alain va se faire
avoir parce que c'était vraiment un ali
fils était naïf alors qu'angela été
posée mais il n'a rien à voir rien voulu
entendre il n'a pas écouté angela c'est
pour ça qu'elle l'accompagné d'ailleurs
l'enfant dans son périple les policiers
se demande alors si le couple n'a pas
été victime d'une arnaque qui aurait mal
tourné d'autant plus que ce type
d'escroquerie étaient alors fréquentes
dans la région on est dans un contexte à
l'époque dans lequel plusieurs idylles
c'est à dire des transactions pour y
ont été commises dans la région mais
également son ensemble du territoire
national et ce cas là elle n'a pas été
victime d'un rip deal les enquêteurs
diffuse le signalement du couple en
allemagne et en suisse il espère obtenir
ainsi de nouveaux témoignages d'autant
que le couple était au volant d'une
voiture qui ne passait pas inaperçu une
mercedes couleur violine
mais plusieurs semaines s'écoulent et
aucun témoin de ce manifeste aucune
trace du couple ni de la voiture
rien n'a bougé
rien qui puisse les résultats les
recherches tant en allemagne qu'en ce
qui nous donnerait à la recherche de
nouvelles pistes les enquêteurs décident
alors de s'immerger dans la vie d'alain
et angela est et ils vont découvrir que
le couple et entretenait de très
curieuse fréquentation
[Musique]
en auditionnant la famille et les amis
du couple disparu
les policiers découvrent qu alain est un
passionné d'ésotérisme et de sciences
occultes les enquêteurs se demandent
alors si alain et angela n'ont pas été
les victimes d'un gourou
car à la même époque une secte
inquiétante fait justement la une des
journaux
madame monsieur bonsoir dans l'actualité
de ce samedi le drame de la secte de
l'ordre du temple solaire 16 cadavres
ont été retrouvés dans le vercors après
un suicide collectif quelques semaines
auparavant au ts l'ordre du temple
solaire a
défrayé la chronique par son son
terrible suicide collectif est ce que
cette hypothèse d'un passage à l'acte
apocalyptique n'aurait pas été relevé
par parlait est-ce que d'autre part dans
la disparition inquiétante il n'aurait
pas tout simplement disparu pour
rejoindre une secte et apporter leur
argent les 500 francs qu'il avait retiré
le matin même à un gourou quelconque ça
arrive dans d'autres cas pourquoi pas
les hommes du srpj de mulhouse vont
rechercher activement des indices qui
confirmerait la piste d'une dérive
sectaire
relevés de comptes fréquentation les
hommes du commissaire aghroum vont tous
passés au crible mais là encore sans
succès
rien ne nous permet d'établir qu'un
appel téléphonique a été passé un
représentant d'une secte quelconque rien
ne permet d'établir qu'ils ont pris
l'avion ou qui sont qu'ils ont quitté le
territoire national donc c'est cette
piste et a eu aucun suicide collectif
n'apparaît dans ses joueurs affrontent
heureusement l'hypothèse est donc
écartée l'enquète fait du surplace alors
les policiers décident de tout reprendre
à zéro ils vont fouiller dans le passé
d'al ain et angela m et c'est ainsi
qu'ils vont découvrir qu'alain n'avait
pas que des amis
ce qui semble évident c'est qu'alain et
angela est était un couple très uni ils
se sont rencontrés quatre ans plus tôt
dans un club de danse au havre ils
s'étaient mariés très rapidement
aux yeux de tous alain et angela étaient
inséparables au travail comme dans le
privé
c'est un couple reconstitué c'est un
mariage qui est récent et ce qui frappe
tout le monde dans ce couple c'est la
différence entre de lui
c'est quelqu'un qui a de la gouaille
c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande gueule
angela l été c'était une dame super
calme alors que alain c'était un peu un
gars super excité la voilà il courait
dans tous les sens on pense au départ
que c'est un couple totalement
improbable et finalement on se rend
compte que c'est un couple où le mari la
femme sont totalement complémentaires et
puis surtout chante ya beaucoup d'amour
mais alain et va traverser une période
professionnelle difficile deux ans après
son mariage sa société de réparation de
conteneurs se voit retirer un important
marché sur le port du havre du jour au
lendemain l'entrepreneur se retrouvent
sans client est criblé de dettes c'est à
cette époque là la descente aux enfers
puisque
plus de moyens de subsistance et
habitués en train de vie est habitué à
aider beaucoup ses enfants
financièrement et il est bien
montrer sa réussite sociale et sa
réussite professionnelle donc pour lui
c'est encore plus dur à accepter cette
situation bien décidé à se défendre
alain eve a alors attaqué en justice les
autorités portuaires et après une longue
bataille juridique il va remporter son
procès et obtenir des réparations une
somme de 1 million 800 mille francs soit
270 mille euros il retrouve enfin son
statut social des moyens financiers et
une revanche contre ceux qui avaient
voulu sa perte économique qui va
évidemment savourer à sa juste valeur
fier de cette victoire
alain s en vante beaucoup à l'époque au
près tout le monde au point semble-t-il
de susciter certaines inimitiés dans son
ancien milieu professionnel c'est
quelqu'un qui avait une façon de se
présenter effectivement vous pouvez
pouvait agacer on peut imaginer qu
effectivement ça est dû énerver
certaines personnes lorsque il
présentait sa situation un peu un peu
brutalement disant voilà j'ai gagné des
centaines de milliers de francs
l'entreprise qui avait perdu le procès
contre le couple e et des déclarations
de personnes mais qui voulait le faire
uniquement d'alcool de l'anonymat disait
que c'étaient des choses et dès qu'ils
allaient passer ses fers et bon après
c'est ptet du cinéma mais bon voilà qui
serait capable de faire disparaître le
couplet pour regagner leur argent alain
et aurait été la victime de la vengeance
d'un de ses anciens partenaires en
affaires après la piste de la ferrari
est celle de la secte c'est la troisième
hypothèse de travail des enquêteurs mais
là encore en dépit de toutes leurs
recherches la piste n'aboutit pas très
l'élément matériel nous permet de
conforter cette hypothèse on a pas
d'appel on a pas de menace on a pas de
demande de rançon on n'a aucune de ces
pistes de c1 aucun de ces éléments qui
d'habitude nous font comprendre que
l'hypothèse est valable
cela fait maintenant un mois et demi
câlins et angela et ont disparu quelque
part dans la région de mulhouse et il
faut bien l'avouer l'enquète est dans
l'impasse et comme les amis du couple
disparu on avait eu l'intuition c'est du
côté du grand canal d'alsace que va
survenir un début de réponse
samedi 18 mai 1996 le commandant angèle
et deux permanences à la police
judiciaire le téléphone sonne à l'autre
bout du fil c'est la brigade fluviale on
a retrouvé une voiture immergée dans le
canal le véhicule répond à un
signalement particulier
il s'agit d'une mercedes
de couleur violine qu'on fait venir une
grue en sort la voiture du canal on
attire du canal
qu'est ce qu'on constate là les vitres
des portières sont avant vitre avant son
décès
le levier de vitesses est au point mort
kluft ramenez pas mis
ses premières constatations ne
laissaient aucun doute aux policiers la
voiture n'est pas tombée dans le canal
par accident
elle a été coulé
intentionnellement
quand vous rentrez une voiture dans
l'eau si tout est fermé elle met du
temps avec leurs pieds dedans elle met
du temps pour descendre parce que si
vous ouvrez les fenêtres l'on rentre
facilement et elle et elle est immergé
plus rapidement comme un élément du
tableau de bord permet d'ailleurs de
situer précisément l'heure à laquelle la
voiture a basculé dans le canal j'en à
la pendule de la mercedes qui indique
2h45 12h45 c'est très probablement du
matin on peut imaginer que la voiture a
plongé dans l'eau à 2h45 coups conjugués
donc forcément elle s'arrêtait
sur la banquette arrière les policiers
retrouvent un sac à main à l'intérieur
des papiers d'identité
ce sont ceux d'angela m
[Musique]
on retrouve tous dans la voiture entre
des papiers on retrouve tous les
éléments qui apparemment était en
possession d' alain et angela le jour de
leur disparition
les policiers décident ensuite
d'inspecter la seule partie de la
voiture qu'ils n'ont pas encore vérifié
le coffre et ils sont loin d'imaginer ce
qu'ils vont trouver à l'intérieur
[Musique]
quand on a ouvert le kof on a découvert
les deux corps complètement compris mais
là dedans avec celui du chien aussi
premières images les corps sont là
depuis un certain temps
en très bon état
dans le coffre du véhicule
les corps d'alain et angela est ainsi
que celui de leur chienne en revanche un
des objets appartenant au couple ne se
trouve pas dans la voiture
[Musique]
mattia tout sauf la malade qui contenait
les 500 milles on ne retrouve pas
l'argent
la disparition de l'argent confirme bien
que si l'argent n'est pas le mobile peut
être c'est quand même un élément
accompagnateurs du meurtre d'alain et
d'angela la terrible découverte du canal
ne répond cependant pas à toutes les
questions des enquêteurs qui a tué alain
et angela est et comment ont ils été
éliminés
les cadavres sont envoyés à l'institut
médico légal de strasbourg pour être
autopsiés et le dossier va là encore
faire un bond en avant
[Musique]
21 mai 1996 trois jours après la
découverte des corps les enquêteurs de
la police judiciaire reçoivent les
résultats de l'autopsié des résultats
qui vont s'avérer plus qu'utile le
rapport du médecin légiste précise que
la mort remonte à un mois et demi cela
signifie donc alain et angela est sont
morts le jour même de leur disparition
le 2 avril où très peu de temps après
une autopsie révèle également la cause
réelle de leur mort
les autopsies vont nous permettre de
comprendre que alain angela et même le
chien ont été tués à l'aide d'une arme
de 22 long rifle allah et à quatre
impacts de balle
au niveau de la tête
son épouse angela et trois impacts et le
chien deux impacts faire là quelque
chose qui relève plus de l'exécution que
[Musique]
que d'une bagarre qui aurait mal tourné
par exemple l'ennui c'est qu'à cause du
long séjour dans l'eau des deux corps
aucune trace adn de leurs meurtriers ne
subsiste à ce stade de l'enquêté les
policiers ne disposent donc d'aucun
indice solide c'est le lieu de leur
découverte qui va les ramener à leur
tout premier suspect le restaurateur de
rosenau charles traiter l'eau
donc dans le canal d'alsace pas très
loin de la pizzeria de schalk et lots
pas très loin non plus de l'endroit où
il a exécuté quelques années auparavant
une première victime née dans un espèce
de triangle maudit dans lequel dans
lequel charge traiter l'eau
résident et le passé criminel de charles
traité lors monte brusquement à la
surface aurait-il tuer le couple est
pour s'approprier les 500 mille francs
en liquide
aurait-il inventé le départ des victimes
pour l'allemagne pour mettre les
enquêteurs sur une fausse piste
face à ces questions les enquêteurs
retourne interrogé charlie traiter l'eau
et l'homme va beaucoup les surprendre
21 mai 1996 les enquêteurs redoutent une
nouvelle visite à la pizzeria de rosenau
depuis quelques jours le meurtre du
couple ait fait la une de la presse
charles traiter l'eau ne peut donc pas
ignorer la faire
d'ailleurs face aux policiers il annonce
clairement la couleur
la première chose qui me dit c'est à me
voir parce que je suis le dernier à
avoir vu aller angela naturellement je
suis premier suspect ça je m'en doutais
avec le passé que j'ai je me doutais que
je serai suspecté ou pensez bien que si
j'avais fait quelque chose j'aurais pas
été le dernier à les voir vivent à les
voir vivant et être déclaré comme celui
qu'ils avaient évident
charlie traiter l'eau est un repris de
justice est un habitué des auditions
avec les policiers il joue la carte de
la complicité
les hommes du srpj décide alors de
progresser lentement pour le mettre en
confiance
il commence par le questionner sur la
proposition que lui avait faite le
couple est pour racheter un restaurant
traiter l'eau lui dit aux policiers mais
attendez moi c'est une proposition comme
sa lancée un peu en l'air il n'y avait
rien de solide il y avait rien de
sérieux on n'avait pas fait de papier on
n'avait pas
matérialisées cette association c'était
comme ça
on en a parlé moi j'étais pas plus
intéressé que ça moi ma région c'est ici
éventuellement dans le sud mais le havre
j'avais pas grand chose à y faire
charlie traiter l'eau affirme que le
rachat du restaurant du havre ne
l'intéressait pas vraiment voilà qui
paraît surprenant aux yeux des policiers
car selon les relevés téléphoniques à la
haye et le restaurateur se sont
téléphonés très régulièrement juste
avant la date du 2 avril du domicile des
de nombreux appels téléphoniques étaient
donnés en direction de la pizzeria et
plus on s'approchait d'eux je dirais de
la venue des à mulhouse plus il y avait
d'appel on avait une fois elle appelle
tous les jours après c'était tous les
jours après on est passé à deux voire
trois par jour pourquoi tous ces appels
téléphoniques
les enquêteurs commencent à se demander
si charles cros ne leur cache pas
quelque chose
[Musique]
les policiers du srpj de mulhouse décide
d'interroger les autres membres de la
famille traiter l'eau
christophe le fils de charlie âgé de 25
ans et christine les pauses
les enquêteurs espèrent faire apparaître
des contradictions entre les différentes
dépositions mais le fils comme l'épousé
confirme le récit du restaurateur les
haies sont bien venus déjeuner ce
vendredi 2 avril à la pizzeria c'était
le jour de la fermeture et un déjeuner
était prévu l étage dans l'appartement
de la famille traiter l'eau
christine précise cependant qu'elle a
seulement croisé le couple car elle a
quitté les lieux presque aussitôt je
suis venu te donne un petit peu marre
c'est son jour de congé
recevoir les prend dans son jour de
congé franchement on n'a pas envie donc
elle préfère partir sa belle-fille aller
faire des courses le déjeuner réunit
donc alain et angela est d'un côté
charles traiter l'eau et son fils
christophe de l'autre
christophe explique que l'entrepreneur
du havre et son père ont regardé
ensemble une cassette vidéo des images
de la brasserie qu'il projetait de
racheter ensemble au roi de la frite
donc traiter l'eau apparaît à la fois
comme le conseiller technique puisqu'il
est restaurateur et le investisseurs
potentiels le co partenaire dans le
l'acquisition de ceux de ce commerce sur
la suite des événements le récit des
trois membres de la famille traiter
l'eau concorde également le couple et
est reparti vers 14h30
charles et christophe ont ensuite
travaillé dans la pizzeria
quant à christine et sa belle fille
elles ne sont rentrés que vers 20 heures
comme ils n'ont pas réussi à prendre les
traiter l'eau en défaut les policiers
vont tenter une autre méthode plus
discrète celle là
comment est-ce qu'on va mieux connaître
charles traiter l'eau tout simplement à
travers les titres traditionnels et
les écoutes téléphoniques qui ont été
installés
les surveillances qui sont faites et
loin de son image de séducteur affable
charles traiter l'eau valeur dévoiler un
tout autre visage
branchez 24 heures sur 24 sur le
téléphone décrété l'eau les enquêteurs
se rendent très vite compte que charles
fait montre d'un caractère difficile
voire même colérique
on découvre assez rapidement que dans le
dans le clan crétel aussi on peut le
dire donc le rappelle il ya lui le fils
de son épouse à sa belle-fille que c'est
lui le chef mais le chef véritable c'est
à dire que tout le monde à ses ordres
c'est un peu un personnage assez
tyrannique niveau familial c'est lui le
chef c'est lui le chef un il a aimé une
pression sur sa famille son sa femme
ainsi que sur son fils au fil des
écoutes les policiers découvrent
également que charles mène une double
vie une double vie mêlant manipulations
et mensonges
[Musique]
l'avis de schalk restelo donc entre sa
femme christine sa son fils et
christophe
est bouleversée aussi par maîtresses qui
apparaît on comprend là qu'il a qu'il a
un jeu très particulier avec avec les
gens c'est là qu'on découvre son
véritable côté manipulateur et les
téléphones à sa maîtresse mais lui dit
qu'il est guidé dans le maquis qu'il a
paris il est des fois il dit oui je suis
à paris en fin de compte ea téléphone de
la cabine téléphonique à côté de son
domicile
donc ils racontent des bobards aussi
bien à son fils à sa maîtresse c'est ça
c'est il a sa vie
il coupe tout quoi se dire que lui la
personne ne sait exactement ce qui fait
quoi comme ça il est tranquille
manipulateur menteur colérique infidèle
charlie créteil ne manque pas de défauts
mais cela ne fait pas forcément de lui
un assassin
au fil des mois les policiers
enregistrent de nombreux mensonges
familiaux mais toujours rien concernant
la disparition d'alain airs angela est
rien ou presque car il ya tout de même
un élément qui les intrigue et cela
concerne les finances de la pizzeria
s'aperçoit que ben on va la faire marche
pas très bien
il n'y a pas beaucoup de clients il ya
quand même des employés il ya un homme
de main qui hélas ces restaurants qui
marchait pas parce que ça on a vérifié
qu'ils marchaient pas par contre
personnels étaient toujours payé en
billets de 500 en liquide et ses billets
de 500 francs qui semble tomber du ciel
les policiers ont une hypothèse sur leur
origine
et si il s'agissait de larchamp d'alain
et angela est
faut pas oublier que la la la les 500
mille francs de couplets sortait de la
banque et il s'était dans des c'était
des billets de 500 francs inquiet car en
liasses qui constituent les les banques
coin et pour la police si charlie crette
l'eau a mis la main sur les 500 mille
francs du couple et il est forcément lié
à leur mort
même si pour l'heure il ne s'agit que
d'une théorie ce type d'élément qui
force est notre conviction mais qui
n'était pas pour nous toujours l'élément
déclenchant l'élément qui pouvait faire
craquer charlie traiter l'eau
plus d'un an après le meurtre du couple
et les policiers n'ont donc que des
soupçons rien de concret mais leur
patience va finir par être récompensés
mai 1998 en surveillant charles traiter
l'eau les enquêteurs découvrent quelque
chose d'inattendu il va fermer sa
pizzeria
le restaurant est en vente parce que il
ne marchait pas et donc une fois que le
restaurant est en vente comme l' épouse
de charlie traiter l'eau est originaire
de les environs de marseille toulon elle
décide de redescendre dans le sud
avec son fils et sa belle-fille donc
charlie traité lors est tout seul sur
mulhouse pour la première fois depuis le
début de l' enquête les membres de la
famille traiter l'eau sont séparés et
les policiers décident de mettre ce
moment à profit
le 9 juin 1998 vers 9 heures un pass de
l'horloge à mulhouse
christian aghroum et bernard de mange
interpelle charlie traiter l'eau alors
qu'il sort de chez sa maîtresse
sort et prend sa voiture on le bloque on
interpelle
il continue à faire le gros joueur le
beau joueur un peu surpris quand même
parce que je pense qu'ils s'attendaient
pas été interpellés
je pense qu'il pensait
que la sphère était terminée que
c'était terminé au même moment à l'autre
bout de la france à marseille christine
et christophe crette l'eau sont arrêtées
à leur tour et conduit au commissariat
ces relations sont passés sans problème
jeudi à cette école c'est pas des
gangsters qui ont fait un hold up ou un
truc c'était une interpellation normal
quoi faire
christine est à nouveau interrogé
éloigné de son mari va-t-elle changer sa
version des faits dans un premier temps
au contraire elle maintient son
témoignage initiale
dans la première audition bon ben on
renouvelle ce qu'a laissé chez ces
déclarations de 96,1 me lis voilà je
pars avec ma belle fille et puis après
le choix je suis venu mais afin de leur
20h30 face à l'insistance des policiers
christine répète encore et encore la
même version alors au bout de plusieurs
heures d'interrogatoire le lieutenant
poirier va battre une nouvelle carte
le policier annonce à christine traiter
l'eau que son récit a été contredit par
des témoins le 2 avril on l'a vu rentrer
à la pizzeria avec sa belle fille
mais bien avant 20h30
donc des témoins et des témoins qui sont
très importants puisque eux disent mais
nous on a vu dans l'après midi une femme
aux deux qui sont venus à la pizzeria et
là il est 17h 17h30
christine comprend alors qu'elle ne peut
plus faire marche arrière
et face aux policiers elle change
soudain d'attitude
comme s'il est un fardeau elle avait les
épaules qui s'abaisse et reprend encore
une cigarette et regarde dans les yeux
assez longuement et dit oui
effectivement de se marier c'est vrai
nous sommes revenus et nous avons vu la
mercedes dès qu'ils étaient là
nous sommes revenus vers 17h ou 17h30 je
me rappelle bien que la voiture des la
mercedes violette se trouvait sur le
parking par contre je n'ai pas vu ces
gens
pour les policiers c'est une étape
cruciale ce témoignage de christine
signifie qu'à 17h30 le couple et n'avait
pas encore quitté la pizzeria
ça c'est un élément tout à fait
déterminant pour nous parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on a un témoignage
direct de la présence au moins de la
voiture en fin d'après-midi et qu'on a
au moins un élément de contradiction par
rapport aux déclarations de charles
traiter l'eau alors si alain airs angela
n était pas reparti où était-il
christine jure qu'elle n'en sais rien
elle explique que lorsqu'elle a voulu
rentrer dans la pizzeria son fils lan a
fermement empêcher tout d'un coup hier
christophe qui sort de la de la pizzeria
et qui vient nous il y venons vous
rentrez pas faut pas rentrer elle qui
voulait passer une journée
tranquillement en famille se retrouve
évincés de chez elle donc elle est née
crise elle pas mais que s'est il passé à
l'intérieur du restaurant
christine ne le saura pas
lorsqu'elle revient enfin à la pizzeria
vers 20 heures charlie son mari
l'empêchera d'ailleurs d'être trop
curieuse
charles ils l'enferment il enferme dans
l'appartement
non non ça
[Musique]
un moment elle entend des bruits dans
laquelle elle entendait des coups de
pioche ddd des bruits mais après c'est
parce qu'ils se savent pas ce que
enfermé toute façon alors alors ce
qu'elle fait à prendre des somnifères et
puis à son bord pour les policiers c'est
maintenant certain il s'est passé
quelque chose dans le restaurant reste à
savoir quoi l'enquète vient de prendre
un nouveau tournant donc en fait ce
témoignage fragilise tous les
témoignages de l'ensemble des acteurs
qu'on a en garde à vue donc sur la base
de ces témoignages on va reprendre
toutes nos éditions
or les aveux de christine ne sont que
les premiers d'une longue liste
[Musique]
le lendemain marseille c'est au tour de
christophe crette lolo fils de charles
de répondre aux questions des enquêteurs
et tout comme sa mère le jeune homme
s'en tire d'abord à sa version d'origine
christophe lui
dans un premier temps il y redire refait
la même déposition la même version
savoir ils sont venus ils ont discuté
ils ont mangé ils ont vu la cassette il
a sorti deux chats quand comme quand il
est revenu les uns n'étaient plus là
pendant son audition christophe semble
plutôt sûr de lui
mais là encore la fatigue et l'usure
vont peser sur l'interrogatoire
au bout de plusieurs heures de
questionnements le jeune homme montre
des signes de faiblesse
[Musique]
et soudain
s'écroule et healy et commence à pleurer
quand les dix ans en compte il faut que
je le dise et moitié tué madame
ekwalla alors non et
on était complètement harper batterie
christophe ce garçon fragile et timide
les policiers ont bien du mal à
l'imaginer en assassin et pourtant il va
vider son sac
voici selon lui ce qui s'est passé
précisément le 2 avril 1996
[Musique]
le jeune homme explique que ce jour là
le repas s'est déroulé tout à fait
normalement son père est le couple est
discutant de leurs projets de rachat
d'un restaurant
il était question du roi de la frite mon
père semblait intéressé par cette
affaire vers la fin du repas nous avons
visionné la cassette que le couple avait
apporté
mais après le déjeuner christophe
affirme câlins et a voulu s'allonger
quelques minutes à cause d'un mal de
tête c'est à ce moment précis que son
père charlie l'aurait pris à part dans
une autre pièce
[Musique]
charlie et
christophe sont dans la cuisine charlie
lui donne à son fils en pistolet un
petit pistolet noir et lui dit il faut
les flinguer
j'étais dans un état second je ne
réfléchissais pas il n'y avait rien de
prémédité on s'est compris avec mon père
sur les ordres de son père christophe
aurait proposé à angela de visiter le
restaurant situé au rez-de-chaussée de
l'appartement
donc ils descendent
[Musique]
et en descendant à l'entrée de la carte
d'un tiers dans l'escalier il lui tire
donc ses trois balles dans l'eau enfin
dans la tête par l'arrière
[Musique]
angela est tombé dans l'escalier je ne
suis pas descendu voir je suis
immédiatement remontés et voir mon père
je lui donnais larmes
donne larmes à charlie
[Musique]
qui lui immédiatement tirs sur
sur à la haine qui est allongé quatre
matches dans la tête
[Musique]
christophe explique ensuite qu'il a aidé
son père à traîner les corps jusque dans
la cave
ensuite il a nettoyé les traces de sang
dans l'appartement
de son côté charles traiter l'eau aurait
mis l'argent des victimes en lieu sûr
mon père m'a montré plusieurs liasses de
billets je ne sais pas où il a cherché
cet argent
par la suite mon père à cacher cet
argent dans un double mur dans le coin
pizza
christophe confirme ensuite le récit de
sa mère vers 17h30 il les a empêchés
elle et son épouse d'entrer dans la
pizzeria parce qu'il n'avait pas fini de
nettoyer les taches de sang et plus tard
dans la soirée son père enfermé sa mère
dans sa chambre enfin christophe révèle
aux policiers comment à la nuit tombée
ils se sont débarrassés des deux corps
alors ils ont décidé de mettre le corps
dans l'art en coffre de la voiture
[Musique]
donc ils vont le long du canal d'alsace
j'ai eu l'idée de les jeter dans le
canal avec la voiture c'est ce que nous
avons fait je me rappelle que cette et
tard dans la nuit il était minuit passé
[Musique]
je suis certain que le couple et était
mort il n'y avait pas de gémissements
nous avons poussé et sommes partis avant
de savoir si elle avait coulé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'il s'agisse du lieu de découverte de
la voiture ou de la façon dont le couple
a été abattu tout concorde
à cet instant les policiers sont
convaincus que christophe leur dis la
vérité
quand christophe nous explique comment
il a tué angela et comment il a tiré
cela correspond parfaitement aux
éléments fournis par le rapport
d'autopsié or à part le médecin légiste
des magistrats en charge du dossier les
policiers personne n'a jamais eu accès
au rapport d'autopsié
l'étape suivante de l'enquète sera
décisive car il s'agit maintenant de
confronter charlie traiter l'eau aux
aveux de son fils et de sa femme
[Musique]
16h45 à la pj de mulhouse le commissaire
aghroum prend connaissance des aveux
obtenus par l'équipe de marseille
il décide de confronter charlie au
témoignage de son fils cependant il va
choisir de lui en dire le moins possible
c'est moi même qui est lui élu avec
bernard de mange qui lui et lui les les
premières lignes de de la tête de
l'audition de christophe voilà mais les
points la première ligne lors de
question de donner des éléments de
détail à charles traiter l'eau il faut
que lui mais nous donne sa version combi
sa gueule conforté
dans sa première ligne à se reconnaître
l'auteur de l'homicide danger là et je
veux soulager ma conscience je vous
expliquer comment face aux aveux de son
fils pour la première fois charles
traiter l'eau par est sérieusement
ébranlée l'ac arles va si un peu quand
même et là il a compris qu'il a compris
qu'on avait voilà avons pris que la cdt
et était joué ils se ferment c'est plus
le chari traiter l'eau du restaurant qui
parle à tout le monde aux côtés
versailles est très très en gestuelle
non il est très fermé et quand charles
accepte enfin de donner sa version des
faits les policiers constatent qu'elle
ne correspond pas du tout à celle de son
fils ben il dit nos critères qu'il
raconte des bêtises c'est moi qui ai
tout fait et compte aujourd'hui
il y ait une grande gueule et se la
péter et puis en plus quand ils sont
arrivés je ne savais pas qu'ils avaient
de l'argent je ne savais pas quand il
était là il m'a provoqué avec l'argent
ça n'a rien de prévu mais j'ai pété les
plombs et j'ai tué c'est tout est arrivé
je les habitués je suis tout seul
charles affirme donc avoir commis le
double meurtre seul et il prétend que
c'est par colère qu'il a agi et non pour
mettre la main sur les 500 mille francs
même s'il reconnaît avoir utilisé cet
argent
les enquêteurs se trouve donc face à
deux versions contradictoires des
événements mais ils sont convaincus que
charlie mans son récit du meurtre
d'angela est dans la cave est beaucoup
trop imprécis
il est très empruntée il n'arrive pas à
reconstituer ce qu'il a fait dans la
cave en descendant la cave ça se voit
qu'il ya une très grande différence
christophe traiter l'eau il est crédible
au niveau de ses gestes et faits et
gestes par contre son père pas du tout
et si charlie avait agi seul comment
aurait-il réussi à se débarrasser des
cadavres il faut porter des corps il
faut les soulever donc comment le faire
tout seul on n'y croit pas trop et puis
comment se fait-il christophe décrivent
les choses avec autant de précision
s'ils ne les a pas vécues lui-même
le monsieur pèse près de 90 kg donc un
corps mort inerte qui font traîner comme
ça seuls ses tresses quand même assez
difficile la conviction des enquêteurs
c'est que charlie crétel au mans pour
protéger christophe mais aucun élément
objectif ne leur permet de départager le
père et le fils ce sera donc à la
justice de trancher
18 juin 2003 sept ans après le meurtre
du couple et le procès traiter l'eau
s'ouvre à la cour d'assises de colmar
un procès qui oppose avant tout un père
à son fils
d'autant plus que depuis quelques mois
charles a changé sa version des faits
désormais il accuse son fils christophe
d'avoir commis seul les meurtres dallas
et angela m
il serait pour sa part totalement
innocent
[Musique]
pas un regard charles et christophe
deylaud son père et fils ils sont
poursuivis pour les mêmes crimes mais à
aucun moment il ne se sont tournés l'un
vers l'autre christophe crette l'ocfc
frappant parce que lors de la première
instance
il est perpétuellement
le regard baissé tout le temps il ne
lève jamais les yeux c'est
impressionnant les gg oui j'ai jamais vu
ça on sent très bien quel est l'enjeu du
procès on sent que le père est là avant
tout pour mater son fils est avant tout
pour l'obliger à adhérer à sa version
christophe et sous anxiolytiques
il semble incapable de se défendre face
à un père
déterminé et accusateurs
christophe est complètement dépressif il
est démoralisé il est inerte il n'est
pas du tout agissant il donne le
sentiment de souscrire aux accusations
qui sont lancées contre lui alors que
charlie le père se défend bec et ongles
avec une certaine intelligence nous on
arrive à la discussion des faits il son
père l'accusent lui met sur le dos les
deux assassinats il regarde son père et
pour la première fois il le regarder
longuement comme s'il part ce regard
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de me faire
mais il ya une personne qui a décidé de
tenir tête à charles traiter l'eau il
s'agit de christine sa femme elle est en
instance de divorce et visiblement elle
n'a plus peur de lui
elle l explique la violence de charles
traiter l'eau son côté dictateur chaque
deux clans et l'emprise qui peut avoir
effectivement sur sur sa famille et sur
ses proches elle est extrêmement
virulente au bout de quelques jours de
procès il semble clair que charlie
traiter l'eau perd du terrain face à son
fils la thèse d'un père violent qui a
imposé à son fils d'être le complice
d'un double meurtre est dans tous les
esprits
la défense va devoir contre-attaqué
m corman l'avocat de charles crette love
alors avancé un argument inattendue il
prétend qu'en réalité le fisc restelo à
des problèmes psychiatriques
il affirme même qu'il aurait commis le
double meurtre dans un moment de folie
quelques semaines
après son incarcération
christophe crétel l'eau il entendait des
voix
il entendait des voiries le menaçait ça
me suggère que le crime qui a été commis
le double crime qui a été commis
là était sous une impulsion
où il a dû entendre des voix seulement
ce nouvel élément peine à convaincre
d'ailleurs plusieurs psychiatres
viendront témoigner
christophe est loin d'être fou
christophe traiter l'eau n'est pas
comment dire n'est pas jugée
irresponsable ni inaccessible sanctions
pénales n'y ait quoi que ce soit
personne dans le dossier si ce n'est
charlie n'est venu dire christophe et
délirant c'est un homme fort qui peut
échafauder un plan de cette nature qui à
l'épaule pour tuer deux personnes et qui
a en plus la roublardise ou l'absence de
moralité suffisant pour limoux y est son
père personne n'est jamais venu dire ça
l'assassin du couple s appellerait bien
créé thélot
mais s'agit-il de charles christophe ou
des deux après cinq jours de débats le
jury se retire pour délibérer
et le 21 juin 2003 le verdict tombe
charles est condamné à la perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de 22 ans de sûreté
[Musique]
son fils christophe est condamné à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle
sa mère est effondrée
quant à la réaction des enfants d'alain
et angela est elle navigue entre
tristesse et soulagement vous auriez
envie de dire quelque chose à la famille
de charles ou de christophe traiter
l'eau
non pas spécialement non il partage un
point de leur côté puis ben moi la
mienne du bien quoi on l'attendait
depuis très longtemps ses jours donc
maintenant enfin
[Musique]
à
la centrale d'ensisheim où il purge sa
peine charles traiter l'eau continue
d'affirmer qu'il est innocent après son
divorce il s'est remarié en prison avec
viviane tardy l'ancien secrétaire de son
avocat une femme convaincue de
l'innocence de son nouveau mari c'est
pas quand je vous parle de l'innocence
de mon époux ce n'est pas allé plus
amoureuse qui qui parle en fait c'est
l'ancienne collaboratrice de son avocat
moi j'ai vu le dossier en totalité je
les lui ai parcouru durant des années et
c'est ainsi que je me suis forgé une
opinion est que je sais qu'aujourd'hui
avec certitude que mon époux n'a
absolument pas tuer ces deux personnes
pourtant la justice l'a confirmé en
appel charles traiter l'eau a bien
assassiné à la haye et son fils
christophe angela deux meurtres commis
avec préméditation
le pourvoi en cassation ayant été
refusée la condamnation de charles et
christophe traiter l'eau est désormais
définitive
[Musique]